[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du 7 8 politique sur tv
78,2 invité ce soir pour évoquer
l'actualité politique du moment
randy nemos coordinateur des actions de
la france un soumise à versailles et
saint quentin en yvelines nous verrons
comment son parti essayé de s'implanter
sur le territoire des yvelines largement
conquis par la république en main chez
les républicains
les républicains il en est membre yves
vandewalle conseiller départemental et
président du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse sera aussi en
plateau nous évoquerons notamment avec
lui la situation de son parti qui semble
fragile depuis l'élection de laurent
wauquiez
randy nemos bonsoir vous êtes le
coordinateur du coût de la france
insoumise sur versailles et saint
quentin en yvelines
première question peut-être un peu
provocatrice mais coordinateur de quoi
sur le sur le territoire combien il y à
t'il d'adhérents sur sur le bassin de la
france insoumise alors déjà je vais
faire une petite précision je suis pas
vraiment le coordinateur des groupes
d'action de la france ont mis sur le
bassin je fais partie de cette
coordination vous êtes plusieurs à la
part de la première qui exactement on
n'est pas un parti politique on n'a pas
de fédération des yvelines on n'a pas
voilà tout ça donc c'est une nouvelle
façon de faire la politique une nouvelle
façon de s'organiser
non à des groupes d'action qui sont
implantés dans les villes dont quasiment
toutes les villes du bassin et ça va de
trappes jusqu'à versailles et en
organise des actions en commun des plus
grosses actions en commun en plus des
dix ont des actions de base militante
qui sont faites sur les villes dans les
quartiers quel type d'action
vous vous réalisez alors là par exemple
al'approche de l'anniversaire de triste
anniversaire de la catastrophe de
fukushima
on va organiser alors au niveau national
une votation pour ou contre la sortie du
nucléaire en france et le 13 mars on va
organiser une votation physique à la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines où on
invite les gens à venir débattre avec
nous de la sortie du nucléaire pour ou
contre et
voilà on vous invite à venir de 17
heures à 20 heures à la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines
le but c'est de porter aussi le message
les idées de jean luc mélenchon
localement et peut-être aussi
s'implanter pour pour les élections à
venir dans les yvelines
alors les élections ça viendra plus tard
pour le moment l'objectif c'est vraiment
de comme vous dites de s'implanter de
développer nos idées et d'être utile
tout de suite aux gens par exemple la
trappe
on va essayer de mettre en place on
ferme on met en place la méthode alinsky
c'est à dire qu'on va dans les quartiers
populaires est plutôt que d'imposer les
idées de jean luc mélenchon comme vous
dites ou notre projet de société
on écoute ce qu'ont à dire les gens on
part de ce qu'ils pensent on part de ce
qu'ils vivent et ensemble on essaie de
faire en sorte que eux s'organisent et
résolvent eux-mêmes leurs problèmes en
organisant des actions face aux pouvoirs
publics face aux bailleurs sociaux qui
résolvent pas de même les problèmes des
gens et c'est difficile de s'implanter
quand même de faire tout ça samson et
lui concrètement sens dans un territoire
aussi on le sait largement acquise
acquis à la droite aux républicains et
puis à la république en marche même si
il ya des il ya peut-être des terrains
plus favorable on peut penser à trappes
sous la verrière
oui alors on est quand même la troisième
force politique sur le département enfin
c'est en tout cas ce qui ressort des
dernières élections notamment
présidentielle il ya un tissu local en
tissu militants qui est quand même
extrêmement actif il ya beaucoup
d'énergie notamment où vit dans les
villes comme trappe ou la verrière ya
beaucoup d'énergie positive et nous on
ne pense pas que ce sont les yvelines ne
soit pas
un territoire des femmes favorables
pardon la france mise au contraire je
pense que il ya beaucoup de faire des
choses ici a eu beaucoup de choses
notamment sur les questions écologiques
voilà nous on sait qu'il ya des gens qui
se bouge et on veut aller les voir on va
déjà les voir en les soutiens il ya
aussi beaucoup de deux mouvements
syndicaux le front social les syndicats
qui font des actions et nous on est là
pour les aider comme on peut on va les
remplacer mais on vous rappel lors du
1er tour puisque vous en parliez du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle jean luc mélenchon avait
réuni à peu près 17 % des voix sur le
département des yvelines se classant 3e
derrière françois fillon et emmanuel
macron on a quand même l'impression que
derrière un peu comme d'un point de vue
national dans les yvelines vous avez eu
du mal à se refait sur cette bonne vague
17 % c'est un bon score pour la france
insoumise dans l'est dans les yvelines
pas de députés notamment sur la 11e
circonscription qui semblait prenable
est ce que vous vous reconnaissez que
vous avez eu du mal après la
présidentielle aaa sur faits sur cette
vague comédie 7% c'est surtout les
institutions de la vème république qui
qui joue beaucoup là dessus on fait deux
fois plus de voix aux législatives que
le parti socialiste bon on a 17 députés
ils ont entre 30 et nous on est là aussi
localement vous en avez zéro tous les
deux bien sûr oui alors localement c'est
compliqué c'est vrai qu' on était
deuxième sur la circo de la 12e
circonscription des yvelines on pensait
faire un meilleur score
mais bon les gens ont décidé de donner
toute la force à la république en marche
ce qui peut être compréhensible même
simon pour nous c'est difficile
comment vous réagissez puisqu'on parle
de la présidentielle un peu un peu
d'actualité forcément comment vous
réagissez aux révélations si je peux me
permettre au tour de la campagne de jean
luc mélenchon sur des surfacturations
est ce que est ce que c'est un sujet
selon vous est-ce que localement on vous
en parle déjà ou alors pas du tout c'est
une skin affaire qui n'intéresse que les
que les médias comme certains de la
france insoumise le disent déjà
non ça n'intéresse pas que les médias
c'est vrai que les gens se posent des
questions c'est légitime mais on a
répondu on a déjà répondu de la semaine
dernière c'est à dire que nous on nous a
demandé de tout déclarer le plus
possible comme ça on était sûr qu'il y
aurait rien d'illégal y aurait pas de
magouilles justement donc on a tout mis
sur la table
on nous a dit cette partie là où la
rembourse sa bombe on peut pas
rembourser donc c'est normal mais tout
le monde fait ça par contre ce dont on
parle pas c'est là les dépassements
de d'un contrat signé de monsieur macro
on en parle très peu oui alors qui a dit
non à la tht attristé par marianne voilà
on est face à avec encore vous pensez du
coin chez c'est un pas un coup
médiatique par un coup étatiques en tout
cas on traite pas les politiques tous
les politiques de la même manière
aujourd'hui en france notamment dans les
médias surtout alors pas tous les médias
pas tous les journalistes mais c'est
vrai que ont surtout le service public
qui revient
hier sur cette question de mélenchon et
c'est alors qu'on a déjà répondu la
semaine dernière juste au moment où
marianne fait des révélations sur
monsieur macro et sa campagne
on peut se poser des questions c'est
quand même pour revenir à delà de la
politique à de la vraie politique parmi
tous les sujets qui font l'actualité du
moment que ce soit la réforme du bac du
projet de loi asile immigration de la
réforme de l'apprentissage ou encore par
exemple de la police de sécurité du
quotidien qui va voir le jour ici à
trappes
qu'est-ce qui vous marque localement
quel sujet sur vous travaillez sur
lesquels vous travaillez pour essayer
justement d'implanter vos idées et
avancer bah on travaille un peu sur tous
les sujets notamment sur la réforme de
l'enseignement supérieur et du bac
nous on pense que ça va creuser encore
plus les inégalités notamment sur le
bassin
parce que demain quand l'université de
versailles saint quentin on va devoir
sélectionner ses élèves par exemple dans
la filière du droit entre un élève qui
vient de la plaine 2 nov la trappe et un
autre qui vient du lycée hoche à
versailles
on sait très bien que même si agen qui a
50 qui a 15 pardon de moyenne au bac qui
vient de trappes et l'autre qui a 12 qui
vient du lycée hoche
ils prendront celui de versailles
pourquoi parce qu'il dure en bas oui
mais le bac n'a plus la même valeur pour
tout le monde étant donné qu'avec la
réforme du bac
demain il y aura 40 % de contrôle
continu donc nous on soutient les
étudiants on travaille avec l'unef avec
aussi d'autres mouvements jeunes c'est
des sujets qu'ils prennent localement
justement est ce que vous sentez forme
d'émulation pour un mouvement social
d'ampleur on a l'impression pour le
moment que ça a du mal à prendre un
concrètement il ya eu des mouvements
lancés par par l'unef notamment mais qui
sont pas forcément très suivi alors
localement ça prend un peu de temps
c'est vrai après
et dans zil dans les yvelines c'est vrai
que c'est un peu spécial à paris ça a
beaucoup pris on a eu quand même de
bonnes surprises c'est à dire un
véritable mouvement étudiants lycéens
qui s'est formée et moi j'ai bon espoir
qu'à la rentrée ça reprenne avec la
réforme du bac
alors on parlait de l'unef du travail
que vous faites avec eux peut-être avec
d'autres partis on sait que nationales
n'ont cessé compliquées entre la france
insoumise le parti communiste aussi le
mouvement génération de benoît hamon
qu'en est il ici dans les yvelines est
ce que vous vous arrivez à travailler
avec les forces de gauche
est ce qu'il ya un travail qui est fait
avec par exemple génération qui est bien
implanté dans le département des
yvelines
oui alors à partir du moment où les
choses sont claires et que on a les
mêmes revendications en opposition au
gouvernement et à la politique de
monsieur macron nous on n'a aucun
problème à travailler
est ce que c'est le cas dans les
yvelines du coup oui c'est le cas par
exemple sur la réforme de l'enseignement
et de la supérieur et de la recherche
là on a travaillé ensemble nous étions
présents aux côtés de l'unef lors de
le l'invasion de l'assemblée générale de
l'université pour voilà pour faire
entendre notre voix
on n'a aucun projet n'est que vous
travaillez ensemble mais selon les
sujets c'est pas sur tous les sujets y
aura deux il y aura pas d'alliance pour
pour l'avenir en tout cas pas localement
pas d'alliance je pense pas on peut pas
travailler sur tous les sujets avec tout
le monde ça s'est jamais vraiment fait
je pense pas qu'il l'ait fait mais on
n'a aucun problème à travailler avec les
autres comptait notamment génération
j'insiste là dessus puisque génération
c'est le mouvement de benoît hamon
ancien député de la 11e circonscription
des yvelines qui a beaucoup de soutien
encore ici rattrape
on le sait est-ce que vous avez des
liens avec génération dans les yvelines
on a des liens sur le terrain c'est à
dire quand on se retrouve dans l'action
après non il n'y a pas de ya pas de
négociation c'est que par exemple pour
peser politiquement il faut savoir un
jour s'allier pour être plus forts au
moment de dans les urnes au moment de
voter est ce qu'il y ait des réflexions
qui sont déjà menés j'imagine que vous
en parlez aussi un petit peu mais très
peu écoutés nous on est vraiment dans
l'action en soutient les mouvements
sociaux on n'est pas encore dans les
échéances électorales on est justement
veut être différent des partis
politiques de cette façon très
politicienne d'agir non on veut être
utile aux gens tout de suite c'est rond
c'est notre objectif
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
disent que jean luc mélenchon est
quelqu'un de très sectaire qui cherche à
tout accaparé sur sa personne sur lui
est ce que est ce que cette image là est
totalement erronée ou alors c'est vrai
que que jean luc mélenchon est une
figure finalement de la vème république
la même qu'il dénonce
non je suis pas d'accord il faut il faut
l'écouter
je pense que c'était le seul
contrairement par exemple à monsieur
macro et où d'autres qui disait ne criez
pas mon nom pendant les meetings ne dit
pas monsieur mélenchon président
mais les triais sur les réseaux sociaux
ils portent beaucoup la parole du
mouvement madi
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui émerge
je pense à adrian quand on lance le
député du nord
ugo bernalicis il ya aussi monsieur
corbières il ya madame lumbago bono il
ya quand même
voilà ça immerge même dans les médias
ils prennent de la place et il faut
remarquer que monsieur mélenchon sûr
mais quand même pas mal en contre et
dernière question d'actualité beaucoup
plus local le gouvernement a dévoilé
récemment un nouveau calendrier pour le
grand paris express pour les yvelines
pas de changement la ligne 18 arrivera
en 2030 en 2027 en revanche sur le
plateau de saclay quelle est votre
réaction à vous sur sur ses possibles
conséquences locales comment vous
regardez cette actualité là alors nous
on est plutôt opposés à ce projet
c'est au niveau écologique pour nous
c'est une catastrophe à partir de 2020
ils vont commencer les déboisements on
pense qu'il va y avoir encore un recul
de la ruralité ça on va réorganiser tout
le plateau entre saclay et
saint-quentin-en-yvelines donc pour
mouvement on est vraiment opposés à ce
projet c'est extrêmement coûteux pour un
trafic qui sera très faible et dans le
même temps vous avez le rapport spinetta
qui propose de supprimer un tiers des
réseaux ferrés de france et en nous on
comprend pas c'est à dire qu'on fait un
énorme projet très coûteux destructeur
écologiquement alors qu'on pourrait très
bien utiliser des réseaux qui existent
déjà les rénover et les utiliser merci
merci rudin emoze d'avoir répondu à nos
questions
vous êtes donc l'un des coordinateurs de
la france insoumise pour versailles et
saint quentin en yvelines
merci beaucoup la ligne 18 on en vient
on vient d'en parler de cette ligne
c'est une parfaite transition avant
d'accueillir notre nouvel invité si le
sujet fait beaucoup parler de lui depuis
les annonces du gouvernement sur le
calendrier cela fait des années que les
rebondissements se multiplient sur le
secteur de saint quentin en yvelines
il fut un temps où deux gars devaient
desservir le territoire retour dans le
passé avec nos archives
on passe pour l'instant on fait du jour
le grand paris express le verdict est
tombé en 2013 déjà la rédaction de tv
60,18 faisait sa une sur le grand paris
express
à l'époque ne dit pas ligne 18 mai ligne
verte
les réseaux de transport et
particulièrement effectivement on parle
de ligne 18 à présent la femme une ligne
verte le projet rebaptisé nouveau grand
paris et si en 2013 la ligne verte ou
plutôt la ligne 18 comporte encore de
gare à saint quentin en yvelines
ce n'est plus tout à fait le cas fin
2014 à l'époque se pose aussi la
question du passage en souterrain
ce qui n'est pas acté aujourd'hui c'est
savoir surfer de leiria et du souterrain
et surfer donc de gao une gare le
problème c'est que l' enveloppe
financière réelle
finalement le schéma avec une gare sera
validée mais c'est alors le tracé qui
pose problème à voisins le bretonneux on
s'inquiète du passage de la future ligne
sous un quartier de la ville et a
beaucoup de maisons où il ya des
micropieux à 15 20 m de profondeur et
donc forcément les gens sont inquiets et
c'est logique sur le devenir de leur
maison si on creuse en dessous suite à
l'enquêté publique réalisée en 2016 la
société du grand paris se tiendra
finalement le passage près du golf
national à guyancourt et il validera
aussi le passage en viaduc à
magny-les-hameaux une option que la
ville a toujours rejeté on va se
retrouver avec une technologie qui est
prêt du tout noël qui est pas du tout
durable qui est pas du tout innovantes
c'est tout simplement la technologie des
années 80-90 du fameux projet météores
et dernier épisode en date pour la ligne
18 il y a quelques mois les élus de
saint quentin en yvelines se mobiliser
suite à des informations parues dans la
presse
nous avons des bruits qui arrive jusqu'à
nos oreilles comme quoi les
parlementaires et sun yang t'es serait
auprès du gouvernement pour revoir ces
choses-là dont nous faisons entendre
haut et fort que nous voulons c'est
aline 18 confirmés dans les yvelines en
2030 le futur de la ligne 18 pourrait
être encore bouleversée c'est l'histoire
qui nous l'enseignent ils vont devoir le
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes conseiller
départemental les républicains et
président du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse une première
réaction sur cette actualité ô combien
importante sur le sur le grand paris
express la partie vit noise
en 2030 la partie essonnienne en 2027
au lieu de 2024 qu'est ce que vous dites
vous est ce que vous dites enfin un
gouvernement honnête sur le projet
global
ou alors encore des promesses non tenues
je trouve surtout que c'est à manque
d'ambition et de vision de l'avenir
j'avais la chance d'être parlementaires
au moment où christian blanc et nicolas
sarkozy ont lancé ce projet de grand
paris 2009 ouais c'était un projet qu'il
y avait une vraie cohérence avec à la
fois le développement du grand campus du
plateau de saclay mais en même temps les
moyens de transport pour s'y rendre tout
cela avait une grande cohérence autre
cohérence et l'ingrat page des coups
depuis aussi la cour des comptes l'a
souligné on est à des milliards et des
milliards supplémentaires par rapport au
jeu posé ici à donner quelques éléments
d'éclairage sur sa leona si vous le
voulez bien
la seconde cohérence cet excès il faut
pas le perdre de vue c'est que c'était
un métro pour relier rapidement la
banlieue à la banlieue
avec des temps de trajet extrêmement
courts depuis le projet a été
profondément transformée à mon grand
regret c'est ce qu'on a dit dans le
sujet avait deux gardiens seulement par
exemple dans l'affairé l'outil alors on
a réussi à perdre certaines gares
essentiels comme 50 à université mais en
même temps on a multiplié les gars dans
l'essonne et on a fait de ce qui était
un moyen de transport rapide à longue
distance un outil de cabotage alors
qu'il faut hiérarchiser les moyens de
transport il faut les transports pour
quelques kilomètres mais c'est pas le
même outil
quand il faut franchir des dizaines de
kilomètres est ce que vous comprenez
aussi l'argument du gouvernement qui dit
qu'en terme tant en termes de coût en
termes aussi de moyens d'engagement
technique c'est très compliqué comme
sujet que finalement une forme de
responsabilité à étaler certains
chantiers pour éviter de se retrouver
dans dix ans avec les critiques en
disant on a été très vite tout ça
coûtait très cher
écoutez il ya eu un dérapage des kooks
est incontestable il y en aura encore
ans un dixième art à peut-être encore ce
qui est certain c'est que en multipliant
les gars on a multiplié les coups c'est
que l'on a oublié aussi parfois en
faisant je dirais des grands projets
architecturaux on a oublié aussi tout
cela avait un coût et donc la société du
grand paris effectivement à laisser
dériver des coûts d'une façon
catastrophique
c'est éminemment regrettable mais c'est
un manque de pilotage pour appeler un
peu l'ampleur du projet puis c'est un
pacte pour technique le grand paris
express
deux mille tonnes de terre extraite
chaque jour qui seront extraites chaque
jour une trentaine de tunneliers en
service au plus fort de la de la
construction du jamais vu en europe des
gars aussi qui serait qui seront créés à
50 mètres de profondeur ce sera le cas à
villejuif dans le val demain pour le
plateau de saclay pour revenir ici
localement
est ce que c'est un coup porté à son
développement et à ce projet de grande
université de silicon valley à la
française
si vous voulez saint porte quand même
atteinte à la crédibilité du projet la
france est arrivée avec un projet global
qui comprenait notamment moyenne
transport est ambitieux celui ci qui
était très ambitieux et aujourd'hui on
est en train de réaliser les centres de
recherche scientifique les entreprises
s'y installe on construit aussi un
centre de logements et aujourd'hui on
met pas en place les moyens de transport
honnêtement j'ai entendu parler
effectivement du transport en commun en
site propre
mais oui c'est une selle aux tendances
avaient en effet rim et tout le monde
sait que cette ligne de bus n'est
absolument pas à la mesure des besoins
on a besoin d'un moyen de transport
lourd le matin et le soir parce que il
ya une population présentant qui se
déplace vous êtes je le disais aussi
président du parc naturel régional de la
haute vallée de chevreuse est ce que
vous vous n'êtes pas inquiet aussi comme
beaucoup d'élus et d'associations sur
l'urbanisation qui qui qui sera
forcément de mise avec 7,7 future ligne
18 est ce que finalement c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour vous qu'on retard ce
projet dans sur le plateau de saclay
pour éventuellement on ne sait jamais
d'ici quelques années encore le retarder
ce que pour vous il n'ya pas qu'en même
temps sedan ces mauvaises nouvelles
quelques bonnes nouvelles a pioché alors
la bonne nouvelle effectivement d'une
certaine point de vue c'est le seul côté
positif du retard c'est que aujourd'hui
comme président du parc mes positions
sont connues
je pense que le passage en aérien
constitue une erreur sur va causer des
dégâts aux paysages
ça pose des problèmes notamment
également pour l'agriculture donc je
suis opposé au tracé aérien
ça fait longtemps que j'ai proposé de
s'inspirer du modèle d'orly val si on
estime qu'il est trop coûteux donc en
passant au sol si on estime qu'il est
trop coûteux de passer en souterrain
mais c'est quand même vraiment c'est le
seul point positif je dirais
la question qui est posée vous le disiez
du coup avec ce soir les valses aussi
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour les douze
prochaines années le gouvernement a
parlé d'un développement du réseau des
bus pour la desserte des des yvelines
quelle solution on peut trouver en
attendant 2030 et peut-être plus tard
écoutez je crois pas aux miracles
le plateau de saclay est engorgé du
matin au soir tout le monde le sait
les transports sont actuellement
s'attirer saturés sans moyen de
transport lourd je vois pas très bien
quelle solution efficace on peut trouver
c'est nous dit qu'on peut rien faire
traitement il faut pas mentir aux gens
il faut leur dire qu'ils vont encore
galérer pendant 12 euros le tcsp c'est
une mesure au bo patick mais qui n'est
pas à la hauteur des enjeux sur
l'urbanisation juste un mot lorsque
j'étais député j'ai été un calculateur
j'ai été à des quelques députés qui ont
cosigné effectivement un amendement qui
a créé la zone de protection du plateau
de saclay agricoles et forestières ce
qui a permis de garantir l'intégrité
d'une grande partie du plateau en
limitant les zones de développement
il y à une autre problématique qui est
intimement liée à ce grand paris express
et la métropole du grand paris là les
annonces se font encore attendre
on le sait les présidents des
départements d'île de france demande une
métropole régionale
on ne connaît pas encore les décisions
du gouvernement quel est votre point de
vue à vous sur cette métropole est ce qu
elle doit être élargi oc à la région
ile-de-france selon vous oui je ma
position est très claire je pense
qu'effectivement on a besoin d'une
métropole à l'échelle de la région ile
de france la région ile de france est
déjà responsable des transports à
travers ile-de-france mobilité c'est
également au l'oubli beaucoup en ce
moment je trouve la région ile de france
qui a la responsabilité du fameux schéma
directeur d'aménagement et moi je
souhaite effectivement que la métropole
soit à l'échelle de la région pour
assurer la cohérence
effectivement de l'action publique de
l'aménagement du territoire c'est un mot
qui est sorti du vocabulaire et c'est
bien dommage
à l'échelle de l'ensemble de la région
il faut quelqu'un pour assurer la
cohérence de l'action mais de vous
inscrire sur ses chaînes de troncy une
métropole régionale est ce que on parle
toujours du millefeuille territorial est
ce qu'il faudra surveiller aux fonderies
collectivités il faut que la métropole
se confondent avec la région donc vous
savez déjà la suppression des
départements
murray contre la fusion 78 92 mais pas
contre la suppression des départements
je voulais que vous emmenez aussi sur ce
terrain là on connaît vos positions sur
la pulsion de la question est la
question est en fait très simple et très
clair je souhaite une grande métropole à
l'échelle de la région ile de france qui
va se confondent en fait avec la région
donc on supprime des jalles la métropole
telle qu'elle existe aujourd'hui donc
pour la faune dans la région la faune
dans la région et on a un outil de
cohérence et d'action publique sur
l'ensemble de la région ile de france
ça c'est indispensable en grande
couronne il faut maintenir les
départements on en a absolument besoin
effectivement pas forcément la position
n'a pas changé
en revanche en petite couronne et j'ai
cru comprendre d'après ce que j'ai pu
lire tout récemment que c'était
également la tendance
une tendance lourde en revanche se pose
la question de l'accueil de l'action
publique sur paris et la petite couronne
très franchement aujourd'hui on a un
empilement de structures dans cette zone
qui est considérable après tout on
devrait peut-être réfléchir à la façon
dont tu as travaillé le préfet haussmann
au 19e siècle où effectivement du jour
au lendemain on a intégré dans la ville
de paris la chapelle pas si auteuil etc
on va revenir au présent et à votre
parti politique les républicains qui a
un président désormais on le connaît
laurent wauquiez mais qui semble
toujours aussi fracturé au delà des
affaires de sonore médiatique il y as on
dirait une vraie fracture qui est en
train de se créer au sein des
républicains entre cette droite
humaniste sociale qui est peut-être
porté par valérie pécresse et puis cette
droite beaucoup plus conservatrice sur
le plan économique sur le plan sociétal
est ce que vous partagez ce point de vue
vous sur cette droite qui semble se
fracturer en deux camps qui semblent
irréconciliables comme c'était le temps
avec la gauche dans le quinquennat passé
coûté et j'ai ma première carte de parti
politique je les prises en 2007 lorsque
je j'ai rejoint l'assemblée nationale je
n'en avais jamais vu avant et je les
fais sans état d'âme parce que l'ump
effectivement été un rassemblement très
large de la droite et du centre
je trouve qu'aujourd'hui la ligne de
monsieur wauquiez constitue un
rétrécissement politique et je suis pas
sûr que ce soit comme cela que l'on
puisse assurer la meilleure promotion à
l'avenir de ses idées notamment gagné
les élections c'est ce que vous pourriez
vous quittez les républicains si rien de
changé dans le futur écoutez ou pour moi
la question ne se pose pas comme ça je
dirais plutôt ce serait les républicains
qui me quitterait c'est à dire
effectivement si les républicains change
de
hinson correspondra plus effectivement
au parti auquel j'ai adhéré
aujourd'hui vous ne reconnaissez plus
vous ne vous reconnaissez plus dans les
idées de laurent wauquiez dans ce qu'il
représente
idéologiquement à droite je préfère de
loin la proche de valérie pécresse n'ont
pas si un membre des républicains mais
qui répète à l'envi qu'il ya de droite
en france donc pas non pas parce que
nous sommes proches depuis longtemps
mais simplement parce que elle a une
ligne politique qui correspond
effectivement est ce que je souhaite
vous pensez qu'il ya un espace politique
qui existe entre laurent wauquiez
éventuellement on suppose
et puis la république en marche
aujourd'hui qui a accaparé le centre le
centre droit le centre gauche
écoutez aujourd hui pourriez être en
marche yves vandewalle clairement la
question je vais si vous voulez je pense
pas que la question se pose en ces
termes aujourd'hui si vous voulez moi je
suis plutôt sur la ligne que défend
valérie pécresse
je suis
c'est parfois complimenter aux marchés
un élu de la république je suis plutôt
mais si vous voulez sur le plan
économique on a quand même beaucoup de
convergences dans la mesure
effectivement où c'est quand même une
ligne plutôt assez libérale c'est très
clair en revanche s'il ya des
différences entre nous est en marche
elle porte essentiellement je dirais sur
le régalien c'est à dire effectivement
sur la maîtrise de l'immigration vous
par exemple sur le projet de loisy
l'immigration vous dit que ça ne va pas
assez loin
ce projet n'est pas assez assez bons
pour réguler l'immigration en france
coûté aux en afrique c'est plutôt le
procès qu'on fait en ce moment où
écouter on sait que l'afrique va gagner
à peu près 50 % de population d'ici 2050
ce qui est tout à fait considérable
on devrait donc avoir une pression
migratoire extrêmement forte
il faut qu effectivement on se donne les
moyens de maîtriser cette pression
migratoire
sinon on aura de très grandes
difficultés à l'avenir mairie ça fera le
lit par les noix des populistes merci
van de waal d'avoir répondu à toutes ses
questions c'est la fin de ce sept suites
politiques prochain numéro au mois de
mars prochain donc dans peu de temps le
replay était quant à lui disponible dès
à présent sur tv 78 points comme
[Musique]